[Music]
on this Sunday night nukes in Belarus
Vladimir Putin's plan to station
tactical nuclear weapons next door to
Russia you have a highly dependent
leader on Moscow who basically has to
follow orders save a rattling or serious
threats
Trail
s for tornado tears through one of the
poorest areas in the U.S we lost
everything but we got our life
a look ahead to Tuesday's federal budget
it could be on the on the cusp of
something that looks like a soft Landing
or maybe a mild recession
why economists say it'll be a tricky one
for the Liberals
and did you see it the where weekend
show swooping down across Canada
global national with Fara Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
there's a new sign tonight of the
growing tension between Russia and the
West for the first time since the
mid-1990s Moscow will have tactical
nuclear weapons outside of Russia
President Vladimir Putin says he will
set up a special storage facility with
Russia's next door neighbor
Belarus which borders both Ukraine and
Russia as the kremlin's closest Ally in
the war in Ukraine and was used as a
stage of ground for Vladimir Putin's
troops at the start of last year's
full-scale invasion of Ukraine
now Putin says America has done it for
decades NATO calls the move
irresponsible and Ukraine says it's
nuclear blackmail Redmond Shannon
reports on the threats as troops battle
it out in a stalemate on the front lines
a hellscape that was once a city now it
is the focal point of a War mostly
deadlocked Russia still unable to take
the symbolic location despite months of
trying
Vladimir Putin told State tv his next
move is nuclear he will move tactical or
small nuclear weapons to Belarus the
Russian president cited the UK sending
arms to Ukraine that include depleted
uranium shells and he's blaming
Washington too that's because it's
estimated there are around 100 U.S owned
b-61 nuclear bombs stored in five NATO
countries some analysts say that is a
false equivalence because unlike NATO
allies Belarus is likely having its arm
Twisted you have a highly dependent
leader on Moscow Alexander who has known
legitimacy at home
who basically has to follow orders the
exiled Belarusian opposition leaders
fiatlana tikanovski has says this
development could make her country a
target for preventive or retaliation
strikes last month Russia suspended the
2010 start treaty an agreement with the
U.S on nuclear warheads a security
adviser to Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski says Russia's latest move has
turned Belarus into a nuclear hostage
NATO was calling it dangerous and
irresponsible but the alliance and the
U.S state Department say it doesn't
change their strategy this does not
really alter the Strategic picture these
are tactical nuclear weapons they could
be launched just as well from Russia
itself would not make that much
difference Ukraine has asked for an
emergency meeting of the U.N security
Council something that would be only
symbolic given Russia's ability to veto
any resolution Redmond Shannon Global
News London
and in Russia three people are heard
after an explosion in a town
southullah region in about 300
kilometers from Russia's border with
Ukraine the blast left a deep crater and
damaged several residential buildings
nearby Russia's blaming the blast on a
drone but gave no word on the drone's
origin
Honduras has broken long-standing ties
with Taiwan and established relations
with Russia's other Ally China
both countries signed a deal in Beijing
today the Diplomatic Victory which was
expected shows China's growing
increasingly assertive toward self-ruled
Taiwan and it also signals a growing
Chinese influence in Latin America China
sees Taiwan as part of its territory and
it's been chipping away at its
diplomatic ties with other countries
Taiwan accuses China of luring with
offers of economic support Taiwan is now
only recognized by 13 sovereign states
we have some breaking news now Mass
protests have broken out in Israel
including outside prime minister
Benjamin netanyahu's home this comes
hours after he abruptly fired his
defense minister who opposed a highly
contested plan for a Judicial overhaul
[Music]
foreign
several thousand demonstrators blocked a
main Highway in both directions chanting
and waving flags and lighting a large
bonfire University students have
announced a strike from tomorrow morning
to protest the proposed changes to the
judicial system that would give
government control over the appointment
of judges and give Parliament the power
to override Supreme Court decisions on
Saturday netanyahu's defense minister
broke ranks and urged the government to
put an end to the overhaul
to the southern U.S now dozens are dead
and homes have been wiped out in rural
Mississippi in the wake of a devastating
tornado a rare ef-4 tornado took a major
swipe at part of the state that was
already struggling Mike drolet looks at
the aftermath and the terrifying
experiences of those who lived through
it
this area of rural Mississippi just
north of Jackson was going through a
hard times before a tornado left it
looking like a war zone it's one of the
poorest areas of the U.S and to now have
to deal with all this
is unimaginable we could hear the wind
and hear the hear the roof peeling back
officials believe at least 26 people
died across Mississippi and Alabama but
it will take time to know for sure so
I'm looking around town
and I'm saying
I know we can rebuild
but what you do with the devastation
what you doing homie
[Laughter]
the worst of the storm hit at night you
can see the tornado backlit by the
bluish flash of lightning it was huge a
super rare F4 that stayed on the ground
for over an hour cutting a path of
Destruction
274 kilometers long
President Joe Biden has now issued an
emergency declaration which makes funds
available for recovery and rebuild we
are mindful of the fact that that will
take time but we are here for the time
it will take in the meantime 20 million
Southerners braced for a second round of
storms through Sunday evening
with hail up to the size of tennis balls
considered the biggest threat micro
light Global News
now to a tragedy in Toronto a 16 year
old boy has died at a stabbing at a
subway station and police believe it was
an unprovoked attack
the teen was sitting on a bench at a
station in the city's West End when
police say he was stabbed Saturday night
a 22 year old man's being arrested and
charged with first-degree murder Toronto
police recently ended extra patrols on
Transit they were introduced after
several high-profile acts of violence
a fifth body is being recovered from the
debris of that fire at an apartment
building in Old Montreal and it brings
the total number of bodies found so far
to five
The Remains have now been sent for
forensic identification two people are
still missing the huge fire tore through
the Heritage building on March 16th the
cause is under investigation police have
confirmed the building contained
unlicensed airbnbs Airbnb says it will
pull listings in Quebec that don't have
provincial government permits
a funeral will be held on Monday for two
Edmonton police officers who were
fatally shot earlier this month
there will be a regimental funeral and
procession for Constable Travis Jordan
and Constable Brett Ryan they were both
shot and killed responding to a
suspected family dispute thousands of
First Responders are expected to
participate in the procession which
starts at the Alberta legislature
and as Canadians still face economic
uncertainty and Rising living costs the
Trudeau government is days away from
releasing its Financial vision for our
country the federal budget comes out on
Tuesday and it's expected to have a
strong focus on Health Care clean energy
and curbing inflation Korea Israel looks
at what may be in store and what experts
believe the fiscal plan should prepare
for
the cost of living these days is already
hard to swallow except taxes go up six
percent this week on alcohol too one
more price hike at a time when it's hard
to find a deal everything's getting
expensive groceries alcohol
everything on a cut down meat
meat and wine we're going to all become
vegetarians to drink tea
inflation is slowing but not quickly
enough
so economists are recommending a beer
and not champagne budget we could be on
the on the cusp of something that looks
like a soft Landing or maybe a mild
recession and for the government that's
those are kind of two somewhat difficult
scenario to plan for
the federal deficit has fallen but major
bank failures in the U.S and Europe are
not helping the global economic Outlook
Finance Minister Christia Freeland
acknowledges the challenges and is
promising to help Canadians who are
scraping by our government will deliver
additional
targeted inflation relief Financial
experts predict that targeted relief
could be another GST rebate economists
say the government needs to strike a
balance don't overspend but don't stop
spending money either and risk losing
Canada's Competitive Edge
the Liberals are trying to lure
investment by positioning Canada as a
major player in electric vehicle
manufacturing the Biden Administration
is moving aggressively on a green
transition plan and the risk for Canada
falling behind is not getting some of
those jobs one of the largest line items
has already been unveiled the health
care funding deal reached with the
provinces adds up to 196 billion dollars
over 10 years much less than the
premiers asked for
the Liberals are expected to expand the
low-income dental care program as part
of their supply and confidence agreement
with the new Democrats the federal
government needs to to walk that line of
keeping spending very targeted otherwise
they do risk making the bank of Canada's
job that much harder a risky economic
environment without a lot of room for
error
tariya esri Global News Ottawa
and our Donna freezing will bring you
live coverage of this year's federal
budget it begins Tuesday at 4 Eastern
one Pacific right here on Global TV
globalnews.ca and on all our other
streaming platforms
an investigation was launched this week
after a series of leaks in Alberta oil
sands went unreported for months
industrial Wastewater containing
dangerous levels of Arsenic and other
chemicals are stored in about 30
reservoirs across the region known as
tailings ponds with an estimated
footprint of 300 square kilometers the
lake is now under investigation by
Alberta's privacy Watchdog it took place
at the curl lakesite operated by
Imperial oil but the incident has raised
serious questions about all the tailings
ponds as Heather York's West explains
stakeholders including both Federal and
provincial governments appear to agree
that it's time a long-term solution to
this dirty problem is found
now my kids that are in the back have to
live with this the next generation of
the Ghana when members from several
First Nations met with Imperial oil in
Fort Chippewa this week tempers flared
and using a lot of gold black attract
emotions have run High since the
community learned waste water from the
nearby Coral Lake oil sand site had been
leaking from a tailings pond since last
May while the company informed the
Alberta energy regulator the public
didn't learn about the leak until a
second spill happened in February part
of the Alberta Freedom of Information
Act that requires public bodies to
without delay disclose risks to the
environment the health or safety of the
public and they didn't do that here and
I'm very interested in why Alberta's
Office of the information and privacy
commissioner is now investigating the
regulator but only about why the public
wasn't informed it feels like we really
need answers more than just in this
specific case was something breached
although that's important for
accountability we need to understand do
we have a broken system and if we do how
many other complaints go under the radar
it's why a federal parliamentary
committee voted this week to have both
Imperial oil deal add the Alberta energy
regulator up here before them and I've
proposed creating a joint Federal
provincial indigenous working group with
participation from the oil companies
because beyond the communication
breakdown there is the greater problem
of the tailings themselves
270 square kilometers of toxic
Wastewater with nowhere at the moment to
go the risk of of having some kind of
spill that will that will get into the
the drinking water something none of us
want to even contemplate we want to make
sure that we have that we've eliminated
that risk so now it's now is the time
for us to figure out what a solution
will be with the health and safety of
people and Wildlife on the line Upstream
residents say this problem can no longer
be ignored Heather urich's West Global
News Calgary
Canadian content creators concerned
coming up how an American Tick Tock ban
could hurt their livelihood
U.S lawmakers grilled Tick-Tock CEO this
week just days after the government
threatened to ban the popular app over
security concerns tick tock's already
restricted on government-issued phones
in that country but this new ban it
would be widespread and as Alicia drost
reports it could have major implications
for Content creators on this side of the
Border hey guys today we're reviewing my
favorite puppet Max Taylor first started
creating Tick Tock videos at the start
of the pandemic everything was boring I
wanted to make some videos to make my
friends laugh and things just took off
from there this is the Run of Mile with
a glass of milk in your hand child now
he has over 1 million followers it
opened up doors to Comedy writing to
ghost writing to songwriting all those
things started in this one space which
was posting a video on Tick Tock but the
app that brought him so much success is
now under serious threat it's already
been banned on government devices in the
United States as well as here in Canada
over security concerns tick tock's
parent company bite dance is based in
China raising concerns user data could
end up in the hands of the Chinese
government the bottom line is this
American data stored on American soil by
an American company overseen by American
Personnel now some U.S lawmakers are
looking to ban the app entirely
University of Toronto PhD candidate
Jordan Foster researches Tick Tock and
says there are reasons for concern but
they're not exclusive to tick tock tick
tock poses many of the same risks that
the other competitors do with respect to
privacy and confidentiality so across
these mobile applications quite a lot of
personal information is being gleaned
about users and users should be
concerned about that Foster says a
blanket ban could have unintended
consequences this is an ecosystem that
has allowed for many people to make a
really generous income in a short period
of time and to ban the application would
cut off many creators and it's not just
Americans who would suffer even with no
ban in Canada losing out on the American
community of 150 million active users
could make it more challenging for
Canadian creators it would have been
almost possible to grow a brand without
the U.S viewership for sure analysts
believe a complete ban is ultimately
unlikely but they do say that users
should have more overall awareness of
how their data is collected across all
platforms Alicia drows Global News
Halifax
[Music]
ahead we're going to take you to the
forest capital of Canada and tell you
what it takes to maintain it
[Music]
major cities across Canada have made
commitments for climate action and
growing Greener but it's the city of
Fredericton that's pulling double duty
and it now has a new title to prove it
Natalie sturgeon has more
important maybe New Brunswick's Capital
but now it holds the title of the forest
capital of Canada the city received the
designation and will carry it for the
rest of the year it was such an honor
and it was also just validation of all
of the work that we've done as a city
the city has two Urban forests known as
Odell and clarney Parks Odell is a
little more than 300 acres with 16
kilometers of trails while clarney has
more than 600 acres and has 30
kilometers of trails and we Define
ourselves with our trees and we take
special care of them so to be
acknowledged nationally for that work it
just feels extra special but it wasn't
just the city's commitment to
maintaining its Urban forests but the
economic investment in Industries who've
made this city their home Pearson is
with the Canadian Institute of Forestry
the organization who grants the
designation and the proposal coming in
from Fredericton was very strong he
noted the city's tree commission which
was established 7 years ago the Hue John
Fleming forestry Center several forestry
companies and the University of New
Brunswick's forestry program all as
additional factors in their decision to
Grant the designation to Fredericton
Pearson also says in maintaining these
Urban spaces requires a lot of planning
serious it's a
decision the city plants 500 trees per
year not only Sergeant Global News
Fredericton New Brunswick
[Music]
the Northern Lights danced across much
of Canada this weekend next these
stunning sites and the science behind
the display
[Music]
they're a natural phenomena that have
long dazzled anyone lucky enough to see
them the beauty of the Northern Lights
can be difficult to describe and just as
hard to see they're rarely viewed Beyond
this continent's northernmost regions
but in recent days they've appeared in
some unlikely corners of our country
Andrew Benson explains
the Northern Lights have taken
Saskatchewan by storm this has been
probably the craziest Northern Lights
experience I've ever I've ever had over
the last two nights residents from
across the province have witnessed the
Aurora Borealis illuminate the night sky
fire was purple pinks Blues greens
yellows oranges Reds kind of pretty much
everything thousands of images have been
shared online of the Northern Lights
from every corner of the province I just
I laid in the middle of a grid Road for
probably 20 minutes just listening to
the sounds and watching the skies
literally dance above me it isn't only
Saskatchewan that has seen the Aurora
provinces across Canada and even some of
the northern United States have seen the
green and purple lights over the last 48
hours
Dale bone and Aurora Chaser and
researcher said one of the reasons we
are seeing the lights is due to the
magnetic field in the northern
hemisphere more particles from the Sun
flow into Earth's atmosphere it
accumulates around the poles if there's
more it tends to expand the Roar and it
pushes it further south so that's when
we can see it above us bone currently
runs the Aurora Hunter Saskatchewan
Facebook group which is now home to over
54 000 members and has gained thousands
in the last two days
for many the experience of seeing the
Northern Lights helps bring perspective
on the world
makes you feel like
they almost lift you off your feet like
it just doesn't even feel real when
you're standing under the sky Andrew
Benson Global News
we'd love to see that just once that's
global national for this Sunday night
I'm Farah Nasser and on behalf of our
whole crew thanks so much for joining us
tonight we're going to leave you with
cheers for Canada's women's curling team
Donna will be back with you tomorrow
until next time take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good night
[Music]